[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers in
allen einen guten Abend es geht hin und
her im Streit um die geplante asylreform
in der Europäischen Union der Bundes
Kanzler hat heute eines seiner
Machtworte gesprochen die nach klarer
Linie klingen aber natürlich nur dann
nötig werden wenn sich die eigene
Koalition nicht auf eine klare Linie
einigen kann aktuell hatten die Grünen
einiges auszusetzen an einem Baustein
der europäischen asylreform und ihr Veto
eingelegt was den deutschen europaweit
den Ruf einbrachte die ganze Reform zu
blockieren wir gucken gleich genauer was
ein Machtwort des Kanzlers jetzt ändert
erst Klaus Brot über einen Tag an dem es
viel um beschränken und einschränken
ging um stationäre Grenzkontrollen und
flexible kein Blick kein Gruß
Außenministerin und Kanzler Kabinett am
Morgen nach allem was man hört erklärt
Scholz hier dass Deutschland seine
Bedenken besser wohl die der Grünen
Außenministerin gegen die sogenannte
gefahrenverordnung fallen lässt um das
gemeinsame europäische Asylsystem nicht
weiter zu blockieren die Innenministerin
SPD aber auch die FDP werten das als
Erfolg jeweils eher für
sich ich treibe dieses Thema weiter mit
voller Kraft voran und ich bin auch sehr
optimistisch dass wir die europäische
Gesetzgebung hierzu erfolgreich
abschließen werden damit wird
grundlegendes verändert was seit 2015
nicht möglich war um Kontrolle in Europa
zu erreichen kann jetzt möglich werden
es folgen Begebenheiten wie sie nicht
gewöhnlich sind im Regierungsviertel
kurzfristig kommt die Außenministerin
ins Innenministerium besprechungsbedarf
die Gespräche sein konstruktiv verlaufen
ist zu hören kein leichter Tag für Grüne
Partei Fraktion Auswärtiges Amt auch auf
Nachfrage kein Kommentar das Machtwort
des Bundeskanzlers ist geradezu ja der
Beleg für die Geisterfahrt von Frau
Feser und Frau bärbock sie wollten ganz
offensichtlich den Asylkompromiss in
Europa aufhalten dass der Kanzler das
beendet hat ist vernünftig zeigt aber
wie katastrophal hier das Management in
dieser Frage überhaupt in der
ampelregierung ist an den deutschen
Binnengrenzen zu Polen und Tschechien
will derweil der Finanzminister
aushelfen bis zu 500 Zollbeamte sollen
die Bundespolizei unterstützen die
zollgewerkschaft protestiert also
letztendlich ist es so dass wir seit der
EU-Osterweiterung die Stellen äh an den
an der Grenze zu Polen und Tschechien
sukzessiv für abbauen und in der
Republik neu verteilen und insofern
trifft es jetzt genau eine Region die
seit Jahren unter personalaufwuchs im
Zoll leidet und letztendlich bleiben
wenn man bis zu 500 Kolleginnen und
Kollegen abzieht für die Bundespolizei
andere Aufgaben liegen beispielsweise
die
schmuggelbekämpfung morgen treffen sich
Europas Innenminister in Brüssel trotz
des machtworts heute in Berlin es
bleiben schwierige
Gespräche das Thema Migration bestimmt
zunehmend die Po Diskussion hier in
Deutschland und europaweit es ist eine
Diskussion die zunehmend emotional
geführt wird und erhitzt aber über was
genau reden wir da überhaupt bzw über
wen Antworten von niils
[Musik]
Mun etwas mehr als 3 Millionen
Schutzsuchende zählte das Statistische
Bundesamt Ende letzten Jahres in
Deutschland rund ein Drittel mehr als im
Jahr zuvor die meisten aus der Ukraine
201516 ebenfalls ein starker Anstieg
infolge der
flüchtlingskrise auch die Anzahl der
Asylanträge nimmt zu 220.000 bis
einschließlich August dieses Jahres
beinah so viele wie im gesamten Vorjahr
und mehr als in den Jahren davor aber
noch weit entfernt von knapp
750.000 im Jahr
2016 doch nicht alle die anträgestellen
dürfen bleiben dieses Jahr fielen etwa
52% der Entscheidungen über Asylanträge
positiv aus kein normales Asylverfahren
mussten Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine beantragen mehr als eine
Millionen flohen nach Deutschland die
meisten schon vor über einem Jahr in der
EU werden ein Großteil etwa zwei Drittel
der Asylanträge in nur vier Ländern
gestellt Italien Spanien Frankreich und
vor allem Deutschland im Juli waren es
in Deutschland etwa 25 000 mehr als in
Spanien und Frankreich
zusammen ja da wird europaweit heftig
mit Zahlen argumentiert die man jeweils
so drehen kann dass sie dann zur eigenen
Agenda passen Italien ruft Alarm hatte
im letzten Jahr aber weniger Asylanträge
als Österreich und Deutschland hat fünfm
mehr Menschenschutz gewährt als Italien
Florian Neuhann ist unser Brüssel
Korrespondent guten Abend florian ist
denn zu erwarten dass Brüssel das
endlose Streitthema Migrationspolitik
jetzt auch mal auf faktenbasis
behandelt ich würde sagen schön W es
aber man muss sich klar machen da
treffen sich morgen die
innenministerinnen und Minister als eine
Runde von getriebenen 27 getriebene
Menschen getrieben von einerseits den
hohen ankunftszahlen von Kommunen die
quer durch Europa Alarm schlagen weil
sie überlastet sind und andererseits
alle 27 getrieben von hohen Wahlerfolgen
und umfrageerfolgen von den Parteien von
rechts außen alle 27 Regierungen spüren
den Druck von zu Hause und stehen
irgendwann auch wieder vor Wahlen müssen
also irgendwas vorw isen und von einer
Runde von getriebenen den nüchternen
Blick auf Fakten zu erwarten das ist
ungefähr so wie in Brüssel auf einen
Herbst ohne Dauerregen zu hoffen ja
Dauerregen scheint es dann noch dieses
Jahr wieder zu geben dann gucken wir
doch noch mal genauer auf morgen Florian
und auf die Rolle Deutschlands speziell
Machtwort des Kanzlers jetzt das geht
gegen die Grünen hängt denn aus
europäischer Sicht die gesamte große
asylreform an Deutschland na ja alle
schauen immer auf Deutschland aber in
der Flüchtlingspolitik erst recht weil
eben die meisten Asylbewerber nach
Deutschland kommen und wenn jetzt die
deutsche Bundesregierung in dieser
berühmten krisenverordnung einlenkt dann
ist da die Mehrheit im Rat sicher aber
das ist nur der erste Schritt dann muss
sich der Rat noch mit dem
Europaparlament einigen und das hat in
vielen Fällen eine deutlich liberalere
Auffassung als der Rat da sind also noch
große Gräben zu überbrücken und das
Ganze steht alles un unter dem Zeichen
der nächsten Europawahl im nächsten Jahr
wenn sich bis Februar da keine
Kompromisse finden dann scheitert diese
große asylreform und dann so sagte mir
heute ein Europaparlamentarier dann
könnte man gleich bei den Wahlen die
Hälfte der Stimmen auch den
Rechtspopulisten einfach schenken
erstmal gucken wir natürlich genau und
intensiv auf den Tag morgen Florian für
heute herzlichen Dank nach
Brüssel in ein paar Tagen feiern wir 33
Jahre deutsche Einheit das soll ein Fest
werden und es gibt in der Tat einiges zu
feiern die friedliche wiederfin unseres
Landes in der Mitte Europas ungezählte
neue Verbindungen Projekte
Gemeinsamkeiten Beziehungen Liebe wobei
bist du Ost oder bist du West höchstens
noch eine untergeordnete Rolle spielt es
gibt aber 33 Jahre mit der Einheit auch
immer noch Trennendes wirtschaftlich
politisch für manche weit mehr
Trennendes als Gemeinsamkeiten weit mehr
als eine Fußnote in den Statistiken im
Jahresbericht des beftragten der
Bundesregierung liest sich das heute so
die Spuren der Teilung Deutschlands sind
immer noch erkennbar Christiane hübscher
mit
mehr Wasser Platz und Ruhe haben sie
ganz viel hier in Brandenburg was es
schon lange kaum mehr gibt sind
dorfknipen mindestens fünf haben in
Nordwest uckerak seit der Wende
zugemacht der Stammtisch fehlt für die
Gemeinschaft sagt Katja nels vielleicht
war der Stammtisch ein Korrektiv wenn
dann da auch Leute sich gemischt haben
wenn man nur Leute aus einer Blase hat
die sich alle sind dann gab kein
Korrektiv Streitkultur ist ein großes
Thema machen statt meckern dachte Katja
nels und hatte mit anderen
Ehrenamtlichen aus ihrem dörfernetzwerk
die Idee einer wanderkneipe dafür gibt's
jetzt 10000 € Förderung vom
ostbeauftragten der Bundesregierung
wanderkneipe ist erstmal noch eine Idee
ein Raum zu schaffen der auch mobil ist
der durch die Gegend wandert wenn es
klappt es ist umgebauter Bäckerwagen z.B
der so bisschen kneipenequipment dabei
hat unzufrieden auf dem Land im Osten
jeder dritte hier hält
Einkaufsmöglichkeiten ärztliche
Versorgung und ÖPNV für ungenügend vor
allem aber fehlt es hier an Menschen so
der ostbeauftragte die große Abwanderung
nach der Wende wirkt so sehr nach eine
Generation quasi Weg ist es für
Arbeitskräfte und nicht nur
facharbeitskräfte sondern Arbeitskräfte
und dementsprechend ist die Integration
und die Zuwanderung und aber auch
Rückwanderung nach Ostdeutschland der
zentrale Faktor es gibt sie die neue
Leucht Industrie im Osten infen kommt
nach Dresen Intel nach Magdeburg
persönlich aber spüren die Ostdeutschen
auch nach 3 Jahren deutscheer Einheit
noch die Unterschiede sie erben deutlich
weniger die privaten Einkommen liegen
heute bei 89% des Westens nach
wendewehen die Karsten Schneider auch
aus seiner Heimatstadt Erfurt kennt wenn
man aber ins Grundbuch guckt dann findet
man wenige erforder die Eigentümer sind
also da sieht man auch die
vermögensungleichheit sehr stark sind
also Anleger gewesen aus München Hamburg
etc die die Chancen gutzt haben ist auch
okay aber es hat diese öffentlichen
Mittel haben dazu geführt dass die Stadt
zwar schönes das Eigentum aber wo anders
gewachsen ist es sind auch diese
Unterschiede die mitverantwortlich sind
für solche Befunde zufrieden mit der
Demokratie sind im Osten nur noch
39% im Westen 59 und die AFD im
umfragehöhenflug in den drei Ostländern
wo kommendes Jahr Landtagswahlen
stattfinden der Osten als Brennglas sein
Historiker wenn man sich die letzten 20
25 Jahre anschaut dann wird man
feststellen auch in den Wahlergebnissen
dass der Osten immer ein bis zwei Wahlen
vorne weg ist was dann im Westen
nachvollzogen wird das ist eigentlich
das Problem deswegen kann pledere ich
dafür sich vor allen Dingen auf die zu
konzentrieren auf die zwei Drittel auch
im Osten die hinter der Demokratie so
wie sie im Grundgesetz der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland
festgeschrieben ist versammeln können
Brüche und Konflikte aber auch
Fortschritte auf 176 Seiten der Bericht
zum Stand der deutschen Einheit ist
längst ein
Fortsetzungsroman reiner haselof ist
Ministerpräsident von SachsenAnhalt
Fragen an ihn zum Stand der deutschen
Einheit nachher hier bei uns im heute
journal Update aber jetzt erstmal Hanna
du mit einer ersten
Nachrichtenübersicht monatelang wurde in
der Bundesregierung über die
Finanzierung der Kindergrundsicherung
gestritten nun hat das Kabinett den
Gesetzentwurf dazu auf den Weg gebracht
geplant ist dass staatliche Leistungen
wie das Kindergeld das kinderbürgergeld
und der Kinderzuschlag ab
2025 gebündelt werden zudem soll die
Kindergrundsicherung einfacher zu
beantragen sein noch müssen Bundestag
und Bundesrat über des Gesetzesvorhaben
abstimmen bundesinnenministerin fäser
hat den Rechtsextremen Verein
artgemeinschaft verboten die Gruppierung
sei eine sektenartige zutiefst
rassistische und antisemitische
Vereinigung die auch Kinder
indoktriniert habe erklärte fäer bei
einer Razia durchsuchten Einsatzkräfte
am Morgen insgesamt 26 Wohnungen von
Mitgliedern sowie Vereinsräume dabei
wurden unter anderem Schusswaffen und
extremistische Schriften
sichergestellt der bisherige Vorsitzende
der CDU grundwertekommission Rödder legt
seinen Posten nieder Hintergrund sind
seine Äußerungen zum Umgang der CDU mit
der AFD der Historiker bezeichnete es
als unproblematisch wenn Sie eine
mögliche CDU Minderheitsregierung im
Osten hin und wieder von der AFD
unterstützen ließe sofern dies ohne
vorherige Absprache geschehe die CDU
Parteispitze distanzierte sich von
dieser
Aussage in einem New Yorker
Betrugsverfahren gegen den früheren
US-Präsidenten Trump hat ein Richter
entschieden dass der 77-Jährige wegen
finanzbetrugs haftbar gemacht werden
kann so sei der Wert seines
Immobilienunternehmens jahrelang poliert
und systematisch zu hoch angesetzt
worden etwa um günstigere Konditionen
für Kredite zu bekommen bei dem
Richterspruch handelt es sich um eine
Grundsatzentscheidung vor Beginn des
Zivilprozesses über Schadensersatz und
Strafe soll abkommender Woche verhandelt
werden die Zahl der armenierinnen und
Armenier die aus der Kaukasusregion
Bergkarabach geflohen sind ist
mittlerweile auf mehr als 50.000
gestiegen das erklärte heute die Armee
Regierung dies entspricht fast der
Hälfte der armenischen Einwohner in der
Region vergangene Woche hatte das
Militär aserbeidschans die Kontrolle
über Bergkarabach übernommen der
Konflikt zwischen Armenien und
Aserbeidschan um die Region schwäht
bereits seit
jahrzehn die Gipfel kommen gefühlt in
immer schnellerer Folge der
luftverkehrsgipfel der baugipfel der
chemiegipfel alle allein in dieser Woche
das ist zunächst mal Zeichen dass etwas
ins geraten ist dass es große Sorgen
gibt in diesem Land und seiner
Wirtschaft ob all die Gipfel auch Teil
einer Lösung sind darüber bereits gehen
die Meinungen komplett auseinander die
Bundesregierung sieht den Gipfel heute
mit der chemischen Industrie die
besonders unter hohen Energiekosten
leidet als Zeichen wie sehr die Probleme
in Berlin wahrgenommen werden Wirtschaft
und Gewerkschaften zeigten sich dagegen
hinterher enttäuscht Manager werden
zitiert mit dem Satz die Regierung lebe
auf einem anderen Planeten Dominik
Müller Russell hat Stimmen und
Stimmungen die Anlagen waren gerade
fertig als Russland die Ukraine überfiel
das neue Polyamid 12 Werk für
hochleistungskunststoffe die ivonik hier
im Chemiepark mal mit hohem
Energieaufwand herstellt insgesamt 1
Milliarde Euro hat eronik zuletzt in den
Standort mal gesteckt neben der neuen
Produktionsanlage auch in mehrere
moderne Gaskraftwerke nun stellt sich
die Frage wie rentabel der Standort noch
ist im internationalen Wettbewerb ich
mache es in einem konkreten Beispiel
fest 2€ocent würde eine Kilowattstunde
Strom in den Vereinigten Staaten Kosten
hier sind es 20 das ist ein ungeheurer
Wettbewerbsnachteil das ist nach gerade
ein Mühlstein um eine der topindustrien
Deutschlands und das darf doch nicht
sein nicht nur der zweitgrößte deutsche
Chemiekonzern evonic die Branche
insgesamt ruft um Hilfe schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren fordert sie auch
einen Ausbau der der öffentlichen
Infrastruktur der Wasserstraßen etwa
aber vor allem eben Unterstützung beim
Strompreis neben evonic produzieren 12
weitere Unternehmen im Chemiepark mal
Standortleiter Bern fend sorgt sich
unabhängig jetzt von von ivonic und den
einzelnen Firmen flächendecken können
wir sagen seit Anfang des Jahres sind
die sind die Produktionen auf einem
recht niedrigen Niveau viele der
Betriebe haben auch schon teilweise den
Betrieb eingestellt sind in Kurzarbeit
gegangen haben Reparaturarbeiten
vorgezogen oder fah waren eben halt auf
Mindestlast mit ihren Anlagen also das
Bild ist erschreckend beim chemiegipfel
im Kanzleramt heute kein Durchbruch beim
wichtigsten Thema Strompreise die
Vorstände der großen Unternehmen
enttäuscht die politisch
Verantwortlichen aus den Ländern mit
großen chemiestandorten kommentieren das
Treffen mit dem Kanzler etwas milder
insbesondere das Thema
Energiepreise war noch nicht so
spruchreif offensichtlich dass man heute
es wirklich zu dem erwünschten
chemieparkt hätte kommen lassen können
und jetzt muss nachgearbeitet werden das
wird in nächsten Monaten passieren man
wolle nun im Dialog bleiben wie der
Branche geholfen werden kann bis
mittelfristig mehr günstiger grüner
Strom in Deutschland zur Verfügung steht
ein staatlich subventionierter
brückenstrompreis ein Weg von mehreren
über die die Bundesregierung eben noch
streitet es stehen nebeneinander der der
die Forderung eines brückenstrompreises
und der Vorschlag Energiekosten für alle
Verbraucher zu senken das ist sicherlich
für die kleineren Energieverbraucher die
weniger intensiv energieintensiven auch
wichtig aber so etwas wie ein
brückenstrompreis nutzt halt den
energieintensiven und das sind die die
im Augenblick besonders betroffen sind
evonic errichtet gerade ein neues Werk
in den USA auf den standortm setze man
aber ganz genauso so der Vorstand man
sei optimistisch dass die Investitionen
hier nicht umsonst waren und doch noch
Hilfe kommt ja die chemische Industrie
also in großer Sorge gleichzeitig zeigt
eine neue Studie der Förderbank HFW dass
bei den kleinen und mittleren unter
nehmen die Lage mit Blick auf die
energiekostenbelastung Zitat
weitestgehend entspannt sei
einsparbemühungen hätten sich ausgezahlt
72% der Mittelständler hätten ihren
Energieverbrauch
reduziert so wir bleiben noch Moment bei
der KfW Förderbank altes Motto wer
zuerst kommt malt zuerst das scheint
Hanna jetzt auch bei der KfW zu gelten
muss man so sagen gestern erst war die
neue KfW Förderung zum Laden von
Elektroautos mit Solarstrom startet da
war der fördertop von 300 Millionen Euro
auch schon ausgeschöpft nach nicht mal
24 Stunden wer Haller ist pace also
schnell sein und außerdem Glück haben
und das sorgt jetzt für Verärgerung ja
und für jede Menge Frust 33 000 Anträge
wurden bewilligt eingegangen sind
deutlich mehr auch konnten nur
Eigenheimbesitzer einen Antrag stellen
die tendenziell ja gut situiert sind
Kritik an der Führung gab es im Vorfeld
reichlich die Frage beispielsweise ob
sie wirklich nötig war schon vor Auflage
des Programms war das Interesse an
Solarstromanlagen deutlich gestiegen
unklar ist auch wie viele ihre
Investitionen jetzt vorerst auf Eis
legen weil sie bei den Zuschüssen leer
ausgegangen sind immerhin wer dieses Mal
nicht zum Zug kam kann auf 2024 hoffen
da wird es noch mal einen Fördertopf mit
200 Millionen Euro geben und dann müssen
wir heute noch über ein ganz anderes
Thema sprechen Volkswagen kämpft mit
einer massiven itstörung was ist dazu
bisher bekannt genau bekannt ist dass es
sich wohl um eine ziemlich massive
netzwerkstörung handeln muss in
Deutschland stehen in zahlreichen Werken
darunter Wolfsburg die bänderstill
ebenso wie bei anderen volkswagenmarken
wie Audi auch im Ausland sind wohl
Produktionsstätten betroffen die Ursache
ist unklar ein Angriff von außen also
eine Hecke Anke die gilt als
unwahrscheinlich das ganze Ausmaß der
Störung ist noch nicht bekannt und auch
nicht wann sie behoben ist vielen Dank
Valerie für diese
Einordnung der Europäische Gerichtshof
für Menschenrechte beschäftigt sich seit
heute mit einer Klage von sechs Kindern
und jungen Menschen aus Portugal sie
werfen Deutschland und 31 weiteren
europäischen Ländern vor zu wenig für
den Klimaschutz zu tun dadurch sehen die
jungen Kläger ihre Grundrechte verletzt
Auslöser der Klage waren die verherenden
Waldbrände in Portugal 2017 ein Urteil
wird im nächsten Jahr erwartet
in Deutschland blieben heute Nachmittag
viele Apotheken geschlossen denn
Apothekerverbände hatten zum Streik
aufgerufen Grund sind Reformpläne von
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach der im
Kampf gegen den apothekenmangel Vorgaben
lockern will unter anderem soll in
Filialen kein Apotheker mehr vor Ort
sein müssen als Vertretung könnten
pharmazeutisch technische Assistenten
Kunden bedienen sagte Lauterbach beim
deutschen Apothekertag der Bundesverband
kündigte für den November einen
protestmonat an jeden Mittwoch solle es
regionale apothekenschließungen
geben zu den Lottozahlen an diesem
Mittwoch die lauten 2 9 19 22 40 41
Superzahl 8 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewehr nach fast 5 Monaten ist der
Streik der Drehbuchautoren in Hollywood
beendet worden die usautorengewerkschaft
hat einer vorläufigen Einigung mit den
großen Filmstudios und
streaminganbietern zugestimmt diese
sieht unter anderem Lohnerhöhungen sowie
höhere Zuschüsse für die Alters und
Krankenversorgung vor seit Anfang Mai
hatten mehr als 11000 Drehbuchautoren
ihre Arbeit niedergelegt Normalität
kehrt in Hollywood allerdings noch nicht
wieder ein etwa
160.000 Schauspieler sind weiterhin im
Ausstand etwa ein Viertel seiner Zeit an
der Macht verbrachte Adolf Hitler auf
dem Obersalzberg bei berchtes Garden nur
5g Minuten entfernt von einer heute neu
eröffneten Dokumentation und Ausstellung
die zeigen soll was der sogenannte
Berghof eben auch war nicht nur
Feriendomizil und Regierungssitz nicht
nur Ort der Täter sondern auch Tatort
Ulrike rötle jetzt über den neuen
Versuch diese bizarre Diskrepanz
aufzuarbeiten zwischen idüll und
Verbrechen in den bayerischen
Alpen inmitten einer imposanten Bergwelt
liegt der Obersalzberg eine
postkartenidülle eingebettet im
berchesgartnerland hier verbrach der
Adolf Hitler seine Ferien bevor er 1933
am uersalzberg eine Machtzentrale schuf
die sein zweiter Regierungssitz wurde
und damit zum Schauplatz der
Weltgeschichte
idülle und Verbrechen heißt der Titel
der neuen Ausstellung also died ist
genau dieser scheinbare Widerspruch
zwischen diesem Wohnsitz Hitlers in den
schönen Bergen in der schönen Landschaft
vor dieser Bergkulisse und den
Verbrechen überall in Europa wo
Entscheidungen hier am Obersalzberg
getroffen worden sind zu ja Verbrechen
zu Verfolgung Krieg und
Völkermord zentrales Thema der
Dokumentation die Demaskierung der
hitlerpraganda denn hier am Obersalzberg
entstanden Bilder die um die Welt gehen
sollten so wollten es die
Nationalsozialisten Hitler als
Staatsmann kinderliebend und
naturverbunden ein volksnaher
Führer jeder Raum erzählt eine
Geschichte vom großen Weltgeschehen bis
hin zu persönlichen Schicksalen von
Staatsgästen wie z.B dem damaligen
britischen Premierminister bishin zur
Enteignung eines jüdischen Unternehmers
den Hitler Zwang Propaganda auf
Streichholzschachteln zu
drucken in berchtes Garten etwa 500 m
unterhalb des Obersalzberg sind sich die
Menschen der Geschichte ihrer Heimat
bewusst es ist ein Teil unserer
Geschichte die brauchen man nicht
wegdiskutieren die gehört zur zur
Geschichte des Ortes bringt wieder mehr
Leute her und natürlich für die Hotels
auch eine tolle Sache einfach wieder ein
ein touristischer Hotspot mehr ich finde
es schon gut dass man das den jungen
Generationen so offen lit am 25 April
1945 bombardierte die britische
Luftwaffe das Sperrgebiet am
Obersalzberg und zerstörte einen
Großteil der Gebäude der Gang durch den
restaurierten unterirdischen Bunker
beklemmend das letzte Wort geben
Holocaust Überlebende den Besuchern per
Audiobotschaft mit auf den Weg nach
draußen und
trotzdem was ich erlebt habe und bin
eigentlich einer der einzigen von der
Familie der am Leben gelüben ist bin ich
noch heute der Meinung das Leben eine
feine Sache
ist am Ort der Täter deren Opfer in den
Blick nehmen der Leiter der
Dokumentation sagt je mehr
Öffentlichkeit der Ort bekommt desto
weniger Platz ist für irgendwelche
Umtriebe so jetzt zum Schluss noch eine
[Musik]
Stabübergabe Daniel baren eine Legende
am Dirigentenpult Generalmusikdirektor
der Berliner Staatsoper Unter den
[Applaus]
Linden und das ist sein Nachfolger dort
seit heute ist klar Christian Thelemann
übernimmt im kommenden Jahr in Berlin
einer der bei barenbäum gelernt hat
aktuell die Sächsische Staatskapelle
leitet
[Musik]
der Generalmusikdirektor wechselt
beethofens fünfte bleibt und barenbäum
sagt über seinen Nachfolger er sei voll
Vorfreude auf das was
kommt morgen kommen wir beide wieder da
gibt's wieder ein heute journal wir
freuen uns auf Sie und empfehlen Ihnen
außerdem unser heute journal Update
gegen 0:30 Uhr mit Gundula Gause gleich
nach uns das auslandsjournal Ihnen allen
ein angenehmen Abend tchüss
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend mehr Extremwetter in
einem wärmeren Klima darum geht es ab
heute auf dem 13 Extremwetterkongress in
Hamburg besonders stark erwärmt hat sich
die Arktis um durchschnittlich 3 1 Grad
in vier Jahrzehnten ein problematischer
Kreislauf ist entstanden weiße
Eisflächen die früher die Sonnenstrahlen
reflektierten schmelzen nun und der
dunklere Ozean nimmt sie stattdessen auf
dadurch erwärmt sich das Wasser und
sorgt dafür dass noch mehr Eis schmilzt
und noch mehr Wärme im Erdsystem bleibt
und das wiederum beeinflusst uns mehr
Wärme bedeutet es steht mehr Energie zur
Verfügung und es gibt eben mehr
Extremwetter aktuell sind z.B in
Griechenland wieder schwer Gewitter mit
viel Regen unterwegs und die britischen
Inseln wurden heute von einem Sturmtief
erfasst uns aber bringt dieses Sturmtief
vor allem die warme Luft der september
wird ja viel zu warm zu Ende gehen und
es bringt uns Wolken die heute Nacht den
Nordwesten erreichen aber meist hammlos
bleiben im Südosten wird es klar
stellenweise bildet sich dichter Nebel
wenn der sich morgen aufgelöst hat
gibt's viel Sonne im Südosten im
Nordwesten bleiben die dichten Wolken
wie gesagt es ist meist trocken der Wind
der dreht auf Südwest und wird Leber die
Temperaturen sinken heute Nacht auf 7
bis 12° im Süden an der Nordsee bleibt
es bei 17° hier erreichen wir morgen 20
ansonsten vor allem im Osten und im
Südwesten wieder über 25° ab fre Freitag
steigt dann die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit
alles in allem geht am Wochenende der
September aber mit ruhigem und sehr
warmem Spätsommerwetter zu Ende
tschüss